lies teenage boys are terrible liars
guys we were terrible liars you know why
we didn't care about quality
quantity quantity they just keep heaping
stupid [ __ ] on top like when my son's
lying to me i'm i've told him once hey
man stop
you're making me stupid like i i you're
not in trouble but
get the [ __ ] out of here
it liz you want to hear the here's the
worst lie he's ever told me
ready for this he used to keep a bottle
of jergens lotion by his bed
i think we all know why the jergens was
there my wife comes into our room one
day and goes
can you
can you ask him to move the jergens
so i walk into his room i go hey man and
he goes yo
i said can you can you move the jergens
it's really grossing your mom out
and he looked at me and he goes i'm not
allowed to have dry skin
i said is it on your dick man because
you're pulling it too much man if it's
dry
you know what else i know about your son
his room smells real bad
every teenage boy's room is like a weird
combination of feet onions and semen
like all the other
oh if you think that's gross i'm going
to tell you something worse so here we
go
you ready for this guys this may be the
grossest thing that ever happened to me
so i'm walking into my son's room
and say his bed is like right here and
i'm walking into his room
and i go hey man he goes hey i wouldn't
step on that sock i was like oh my god
[Applause]
you got to put your nut rag in the
hamper like everybody else you know what
i mean
it looked like there was a pencil under
a sock is what it looked like
and it was sharp like you could have
killed someone in jail with that sock
like
like a shank sock he almost got my
[ __ ] foot pregnant like it was sharp
he smells but you know what i did to him
guys i like to [ __ ] with my kids and so
the sock incident three months after the
sock incident was his birthday
and so on his birthday i bought him a 12
pack of silk socks
with a note on it that just said treat
yourself
you got to be good to you you know what
i mean
[Music]
you